(upbeat music)
- Ah shit!
Yeah!
Here we go.
(audience cheers)
Black people, we don't even
get our hands on opioids.
(audience laughs)
They don't even give 'em to us.
I had a double mastectomy.
You know what they sent
my black ass home with?
Ibu-fuckin-profen.
(audience laughs)
White people get opioids
like they Tic Tacs.
I'm at work, and I'm like,
"Damn, I got a headache."
White people start pullin' out
all kind of pills and shit!
Just fuckin' loose pills in Ziploc bags.
(audience cheers)
(audience laughs)
"Would you like an Oxycodone?"
"No, she should take a Percocet."
Other girl over there
is preparin' a needle.
"Give me your arm!"
(audience laughs)
This is shit is not normal.
(audience cheers)
Boom, boom! (rolls tongue)
(microphone thumps)
Ah, yes!
Yes!
(upbeat music)